واكدان صعوبه معارك السيطره على بخموت
يقول ان الامور مؤلمه للغايه
بعد تجربتين صاروخيتين جديدتين
هبوط اسهم البنوك العالميه بعد انهيار بنك
سيليكون فالي رغم تضمينات المسؤولين
الامريكيين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم اكدت كل من القوات الاوكرانيه
والروسيه انها تخوض معارك عنيفه للسيطره
على وسط مدينه باخموت في شرق اوكرانيا
ووفقا لقائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
الكسندر سيرسكي فانه وحدات هجوميه تابعه
للمجموعه الروسيه المسلحه فاجنر تهاجم من
اتجاهات عده في محاوله للتقدم نحو احياء
الوسط من جهته قال يفغيني بريكوجين رئيس
مجموعه فاجنر انه كلما اقترب مقاتلون
مجموعه من وسط باخمد ازدادت المعارك قسوه
وكان هناك استخدام للمدفعيه ومنذ اشهر
تحولت مدينه باخموت الى مركز للمعارك على
الجبهه الشرقيه في اوكرانيا
لذلك قال الرئيس الاوكراني
صعبه جدا في الشرق الاوكراني ومؤلمه
للغايه واكد الرئيس الاوكراني ضروره تدمير
القوه العسكريه للقوات الروسيه مشيرا الى
ان مستقبل اوكرانيا يعتمد على نتائج
المعارك في شرق البلاد
وتتسارع عمليات تدريب القوات الاوكرانيه
في عدد من البلدان الاوروبيه كابولندا
والمانيا واسبانيا على دبابات
وامل الغرب ان تغير الدبابات مجرى المعارك
في عدد من الجبهات المشتعله في اوكرانيا
خلال الاشهر القادمه
يتدربون اثنتي عشره ساعه في اليوم لسته
ايام في الاسبوع يصارعون عدوهم الاول
الوقت يطوعون ثلاثه اشهر من التدريب
الالزامي في خمسه او ثمانيه اسابيع كحد
اقصى ويعيدون بناء جيش قادرا على استعمال
الات الحرب الحديثه فعشرون بالمئه فقط من
الجيش الاوكراني قادر على التعامل مع
الدبابات الحربيه في ساعات الصباح الاولى
يبدا الجنود الاوكراني التدريب في مركز
سان جورجو العسكري في زيرا جوزا شرقيه
اسبانيا حوالي 55 جنديا يتدربون على قطع
تحاكي العمل على الدبابات الحقيقيه قبل
خروجهم الى معسكرات التدريب تتطلب دبابه
ليو بارد الواحده طاقما يتكون من اربعه
جنود لتشغيلها بالمقابل فهي تقدم مميزات
عده تجعل قرار ارسال مئات الجنود الاوكران
للتدريب في خضم الحرب قرارا مهما ويعد
مدفع دبابه ليوبارد اثنان من اهم الميزات
الموجوده فيها اذ يمتلك قدره ثبات عاليه
على الاراضي غير المستويه بسرعه 70
كيلومترا مدعوما بنظام تحكم رقمي ميزه
تفتقر لها الدبابات الاوكرانيه التي تعود
لعهد الاتحاد السوفيتي كما ان مقدمه
الدبابه مدعومه بصفائح مضاده للالغام ميزه
اخرى امام الالغام الروسيه الذكيه التي
تقفز من مكانها لاقتناس الدبابات
الاوكرانيه
يظل تحدي الاكبر هو امكانيه توظيف
التدريبات المكثفه التي تلقاها الجنود في
ميدان المعارك المشتعله الذي سيكون الحسم
في رهان الغربي على هذه الدبابات كرم
حناوي العربيه
ذكرت وكاله توتاس الروسيه نقلا عن مصادر
ان اتفاق تصدير الحبوب من موانئ البحر
الاسود سيتم تمديده تلقائيا بعد انتهاء
العمل به يوم الثامن عشر من مارس ما لم
يوجد اي اعتراض لدى اي من الاطراف
المشاركه فيه وقالت الوكاله نقلا عن مصدر
مطلع ان كل الاطراف المشاركه في الاتفاق
لم تلمح الى انسحابها حتى الان غير ان
روسيا تطالب بتخفيض مدته الى شهرين بدلا
من اربعه
اعلنا الجيش الكوري الجنوبي ان كوريا
الشماليه اطلقت صاروخين بالسيتين قصيري
المدى من اقليم هوانغاي الجنوبي قرب
الساحل الغربي للبلاده وقالت هيئه الاركان
المشتركه الكوريه الجنوبيه ان الجيش على
درجه تاهب عاليه وفي وضع الجاهزيه الكامله
بتنسيق وثيق مع الولايات المتحده ياتي ذلك
غدادا انطلاق مناورات عسكريه امريكيه
كوريا الجنوبيه مشتركه هي الاوسع نطاقا
منذ خمس سنوات
وصف رئيس الوزراء الاسترالي انطوني
البانيزي شراء شراء بلاده غواصات امريكيه
تعمل بدفع النووي وانخراطها في مشروع
لبناء جيل جديد من الغواصات بانه اكبر
استثمار عسكري في تاريخ استراليا وستشتري
استراليا 5 غواصات امريكيه تعمل بالدفع
النووي كما ستتعاون في مرحله لاحقه مع
الولايات المتحده والمملكه المتحده لبناء
جيل جديد من الغواصات لتعزيز الحضور
العسكري الغربي في منطقه اسيا والمحيط
الهادئ في مواجهه صعود النفوذ الصينيه جاء
اعلان الاتفاق في اجتماع استضافه الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن والتقى خلاله رئيسي
وزراء استراليا وبريطانيا في قاعده
ساندييغو البحريه في ولايه كاليفورنيا
اتخذنا خطوه كبيره لتعزيز اتفاقيه امريكا
وبريطانيا واستراليا اوكوس وسنضمن
لاستراليا بناء اسطول متطورا من الغواصات
النوويه وسنعمل على شراكات اخرى لتعزيز
اسطول استراليا الدفاعي ويجب الاشاره الى
ان تحالف اوكوس سيعزز التنسيق بشان
الغواصات النوويه مع بريطانيا واستراليا
الشراكه مع لندن وكامبيرا بهذا الشان
ستفتح وظائف كثيره ونؤكد على ان الغواصات
الاستراليه ستعمل بالطاقه النوويه ولا
تحمل اسلحه نوويه
قلع رئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب ان
اعاده انتخابه فقط كرئيس للولايات المتحده
في عام 2024 ستنقذ البلاد من خطر اندلاع
الحرب العالميه الثالثه واضاف ترامب خلال
مؤتمر انتخابيه انه يعتقد بشده في اندلاع
حرب عالميه ثالثه مهاجما اداره جو با يدن
التي اكد انها لا ترسل الاشارات الصحيحه
ولا تعرف ما يجب فعله لمنع المخاطر واشار
الى ان السيناريوهات الحاليات تشير الى
الدخول في حرب كبيره مع الصين وغيرها
ولفتا الى انه سيقرر الاستمرار في ارسال
الاسلحه لاوكرانيا من عدمه اذا تم انتخابه
رئيسا بعد اجتماع مع الرئيس الروسي
نشرتنا مستمره فيها بعض الفاصل
قيادات احزاب سودانيه تطالب الجيش بضبط
النفس وتفويت الفرصه على مستهدفي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد دعا عقيله صالح رئيس
مجلس نواب الليبي الى تشكيل حكومه جديده
ومده محدده لتنفيذ القوانين والاشراف على
الانتخابات وقال صالح ان الجانب التشريعي
والقوانين التشريعيه لانجاز الانتخابات
ستكون جاهزه قبل يونيو داعيا المفوضيه الى
فتح سجل الناخبين من جديد كما اكد صالح
اسرار المجلس على اجراء الانتخابات في
موعدها المحدد وان لا يتم استبعاد احد من
الترشح الا طبقا للقانونه واتهم رئيس مجلس
النواب رئيسه حكومه الوحده الوطنيه عبد
الحميد دبيبه بالتسبب في عرقله الانتخابات
بسبب ترشحه للرئاسه رغم تعهده سابقا بعدم
الترشح كما وجه صالح انتقاده للمبعوث
الاممي عبد الله بتيلي الذي وصف مؤسسات
ليبيه بانها منتهيه الصلاحيه وقال صالح
انباتيلي ليس حاكما لليبيا ولا يجوز ان
يحل محل الليبيين
نشد عشره من قيادات الاحزاب والكيانات في
السودان وفي مقدمتهم رئيس حزب الامه
القوميه المكلف فضل الله بورما ونائب رئيس
الحزب الاتحادي الديمقراطي الاصل جعفر
الصادق ناشدوا القوات النظاميه بالتحلي
بضبط النفس وتفويت الفرصه على القوى التي
تستهدف وحده السودان وامنه كما نشدت
قيادات الاحزاب القوى السياسيه والمدنيه
التحلي بروح المسؤوليه والقيام بواجباتها
الوطنيه
والسموع على الخلافات وتقديم مصلحه الوطن
على المصالح الضيقه
في المغرب انتقد الديوان الملكي حزب
العداله والتنميه لتدخله في السياسات
الخارجيه ووصف الديوان بيانا صادرا عن
الحزب بشان العلاقات مع اسرائيل بانه غير
موضوعي وفيه مغالطات كثيره
اعتبر الديوان الملكي في المغرب ان حزب
العداله والتنميه اصدر بيانا تضمن تجاوزات
غير مسؤوله ومغالطات خطيره عن علاقات
المغرب مع اسرائيل وربطها بالتطورات في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله انعلم جميعا
وقع القضيه الفلسطينيه على وجدان المغاربه
وهي تاتي في نفس المرتبات قضيه الوحده
الترابيه وبالتالي فان قوه ديون سياسيه من
خلال عشر سنوات عجاف تحاول اللعب على
عواطف المغاربه من خلال مزايده بقضيه
الفلسطينيه وبالتالي لا يمكن استغلال
التحولات الاقليميه للمشاهده بهدف عوده
انتخابيين او سياسويا الديوان الملكي في
المغرب اوضح ان القضيه الفلسطينيه من
اولويات السياسه الخارجيه للعاهل المغربي
الملك محمد السادس بالاخذ الملك تجهز
العداله والتنميه حيال التطورات ديال
القضيه الفلسطينيه يعبر عن انزعاج واضح من
خلال البلاغ ولغته من المواقف التي يعبر
عليها حزب العداله والتنميه عشر سنوات من
التدبير في الحكومه للعداله والتنميه
ومشاركه اكثر من 14 وزير وكون رئيس حكومه
سابق سعد الدين العثماني وزير خارجيه في
لحظه من اللحظات تقتضي ان يفهم ان المخطط
والذي يراس
للخارجيه هو ملك البلاد في رساله مباشره
الى اخوان المغرب اعتبر الديوان الملكي
المغربي ان مواقف الرباط لا تخدع
للمزايدات السياسيه او للحملات الانتخابيه
الضيقه فيما العداله والتنميه طالب قيادته
وقواعده بعدم التعليق باي شكل من الاشكال
تكراره هجوم حزب العداله والتنميه المعارض
على الدبلوماسيه المغربيه على خلفيه
القضيه الفلسطينيه دفع بحسب مراقبين
السلطات المغربيه الى اصدار بيان شديد
الله جه يوضح مواقف الرباط من القضيه
الفلسطينيه ويوضح طبيعه استئناف العلاقات
المغربيه الاسرائيليه عادل الزبير العربيه
الرباط
ادت تداعيات انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي
الاستمراري خسائر اسهم البنوك العالميه
صباح الثلاثاء رغم محاولات رئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن وغيره من المسؤولين لتهدئه
الاسواق كما انخفضت اسعار النفط اليوم
مواصله خسائرها للجلسه الثانيه اذ ادى
انهيار البنك الى هزه في اسواق الاسهم
واثار مخاوف من وقوع ازمه ماليه جديده
اليوم وجهت الاداره بالتحرك سريعا لاحتواء
تداعيات انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي بامكان
المودعين الوصول الى اموالهم بدون عوائق
المستثمرون الذين يخاطرون بودائع
الامريكيين ستتم محاسبتهم ولن تكون هناك
حمايه لاصحاب قرارات المخاطر التي ادت
لهذه الازمه ولن نسمح بتكرار اخفاقات
البنوك وسنعمل على حمايه الشركات الناشئه
اريد التاكيد على ان دافعي الضرائب لن
يتحملوا اي خسائر بسبب ازمه البنوك
اجراءات عده اتخذتها وزاره الخزانه
الامريكيه بالتشاوري مع الرئيس جو بايدن
ومع البنك الاحتياطي الفيدرالي لتجنب
تداعيات انهيار بنك سيليكون فالي ولتمكين
المودعين من الحصول على اموالهم ان الله
اكرر لا خسائر سيتحملها دافع والضرائب من
اهم ما اكد عليه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
خلال كلمته هو ان جميع اموال المودعين
ودافعي الضرائب في البنوك مؤمنه ويمكن
الحصول عليها من دون عائق وطلب من
الامريكيين الثقه في النظام المصرفي فقبل
هذه الازمه كانت الحكومه الفيدراليه تضمن
من خلال المؤسسه الفيدراليه للتامين على
الودائع الودائع التي لا تزيد قيمتها عن
250 الف دولار
قاعده 250 الف دولار ستستمر ولن تتراجع
الحكومه عنها السبب الوحيد لتعليقها
للبنكين منع العدو المالي لكن الحكومه
ستغير بعض اللوائح في المستقبل لمحاوله
الحد من اي خطر معنوي ربما يكون قد تسببوا
فيه عبر اقتراح ان الحكومه ستتدخل دائما
لانقاذ المودعين لكن الوضع بالنسبه
للمستثمرين الذين يخاطرون بودائع
الامريكيين مختلف وفق بايدن لانهم لن
يحظوا باي حمايه فيما تعهد بمحاسبه
المسؤولين عن ازمه البنوك معتبرا ان لا
احد فوق القانون
سيتم طرد اداره هذه البنوك اذا تم
الاستيلاء على البنك من قبل المؤسسه
الفيدراليه للتامين على الودائع فيجب على
الاشخاص الذين يديرون البنك الا يعملوا
هناك بعد الان
وعد بان الاجراءات لحمايه المودعين ولعدم
تكرار اخفاقات البنوك ستستمر الى ان تنتهي
ازمه مصرفي سيليكون
فيما سيطلب من الكونجرس تجديد القوانين
المتعلقه بالبنوك حسين الطاوض العربيه
واشنطن في الاثناء قال الرئيس التنفيذي
لبنك السيليكون فالي انه بامكان المودعين
الوصول بحريه لاموالهم وان الودائع محميه
مؤكدا في الوقت ذاته ان اداره البنك تسير
الاعمال التجاريه كالمعتاد داخل الولايات
المتحده وتوقع الرئيس التنفيذي لبنك
سيليكون فالي استئناف المعاملات عبر
الحدود في الايام المقبله
[موسيقى]
وتشد الاسواق الاسيويه موجه تراجعات كبرى
في بورصات اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه وهونج
كونج وتراجع مؤشر
الياباني بنحو 600 نقطه باكثر من 2.5 كمان
انخفض مؤشر كوسبي في كوريا الجنوبيه بنحو
2% بسبب مخاوف المستثمرين تزامنا مع ازمه
البنوك الامريكيه
قالت السفاره الصينيه في الولايات المتحده
انها ستستانف اصدار تاشيرات الدخول بمختلف
انواعها للاجانب اعتبارا من يوم غد
الاربعاء بعد ان اتخذت الصين اجراءات
صارمه لاحتواء فيروس كورونا واضافت
السفاره الصينيه في بيان ان سترفع ايضا
قيود تاشيرات على مختلف المواقع بما في
ذلك جزيره هاينان وسفن السياحيه التي تمر
عبر ميناء شنغهاي كما ستسمح الصين
باستئناف في دخول الاجانب دون تاشيره الى
اقليم كوانت دونج من هونغ كونغ ومكا
لا تزال مياه الفيضانات تغمر اجزاء من
منطقه باجارو الساحليه بولايه كاليفورنيا
الامريكيه بعد انهيار سد على نهر باجاروما
ادى الى تدفق مياه غزيره عبر الاحياء
واجراء عمليات اجلاء طارئه في الصباح هذا
واصبحت الفيضانات تحدث بشكل متكرر في
كاليفورنيا هذا العام مع سلسله من العواصف
التي تضرب الساحل منذ اواخر ديسمبر الماضي
كما حذرت خدمه الارصاد الجويه الوطنيه من
حدوث فيضانات اخرى في معظم انحاء الولايه
[موسيقى]
مهما ارتفعت الجدران على الحدود ستبقى
مسيرات المهاجرين على حالها مكسيكيون
وغيرهم يحملون ما خفه وزنه مع اطفالهم
سعيا للعبور الى ارض الاحلام سلطات انفاذ
القانون نجحت في التصدي لهذه الموجه
الجديده
النشره تذكيرهم بالعناوين
موسكو صعوبه معارك السيطره على باخمد
وسيلينسكي يقول ان الامور مؤلمه للغايه
بعد تجربتين صاروخيتين جديدتين ليبيونغ
سول تعلن ان جيشها متاهب وينسق مع واشنطن
هبوط اسهم البنوك العالميه بعد انهيار بنك
سيليكون فالي رغم تطوينات المسؤولين
الامريكيين
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]